this video it's a real chess explained
again okay
who on earth is that
oh okay
so we have a London with black and this
is a line that is fairly comfortable
form for me black has good chances of
being completely equal quickly here
night age form early
there was a quick decision how does he
handle this now that's interesting
a night on h4 is I mean there's still
Knight to f5 but got my doubts him I'm a
third inning g5 plain and simple
okay now how do we go about this
hmm I take on d4 he has to take with the
e pawn if I then play Queen a5 the
knight is hanging and I have Knight
takes d4 in many cases okay
I also have g6 here g6 93 it doesn't
have many squares
[Music]
a couple of interesting things I'm not
not certain what's the best really okay
what I can do is I can do this
96 takes takes it takes this simply okay
[Music]
hmm did not expect that
okay so if I take with the bishop it's
probably probably best now a g7 is
trapping in the night after king of 893
is he fine so he has to do this and now
I can this one of course I can take and
play I wanted to play with the age
[Music]
I wonder about castling long if that is
the thing
[Music]
it's interesting
I guess Bishop g3 if he goes to a 395 is
just going to be good for me so he goes
to g3
yeah both is good
oh it's both good I don't know what's
better
I got 23 seconds so sister the main main
issue here position is fantastic I mean
fantastic I don't know but it's quite
quite substantially better for black
efore I can check play d2
[Music]
18 seconds
I spotted Bishop c5 but I have Queenie
Jew wanted to go wants to go to c4 after
c6 five seconds
it's will be tough to do
with the term situation
twin b3 is some very annoying doesn't do
it okay
you should see three there's Quincy
Quinn tags
Quincy five was maybe stronger even
attacking the book that's what I
originally wanted to play I was probably
indeed better now it's nothing going on
[Music]
yeah but at least I'm not probably
losing on time I can I can take no no no
no no it was very very bad problem
what a crazy play what I did here was so
crazy and it was I mean I got enough
time here to figure it out there was no
reason to to play it like that okay okay
okay I definitely miss twins there I
think the position was so good but I
spent such a huge amount of time in the
opening so it got it got weird
once he opted for this we should before
his fairly normal reaction to such a
move 92-86 this is how he do it
but the engine already says that he
takes a strong song the engine wants to
do this but he's five Wow
I mean it is it looks strong if you look
at this it's very interesting very
interesting
so probably even today taking was
probably better okay I went age six
after which he took on a form and played
Knight f5 and here I was searching for
the best solution but I couldn't quite
figure it out
if I take he has to check with the e
pawn gnome I mean this is not good
so here and now I didn't quite see how I
can punish him something like is 693
isn't that great yeah I mean II 6 is
probably ok he took on c5 I was mostly
thinking about this when I wanted to
play here and take on loops and take on
d4 that was my my plan but he took on c5
takes this now along and now Bishop g3
is kind of the normal move
I intended to double on the D file then
one night h5 which turns out to be
stronger simply take and then 95 so
something like this is probably what
should happen I had he's got a bad
nervous system yeah this is a prison
issue if you if you are in those time
scrambles it's it's I have to keep keep
your cool somehow tough decision
rook takes is also great I have a full D
file control well this is better and
okay we had both no much time and I
probably nine age five is not good but I
wonder about about this ham
rook t3 so the a bishop c5 is is good I
mean I was just thinking I go here and
I'm so active that I couldn't quite
believe that he can take here it doesn't
seem to be the case here
Luke g1 and somehow this is not winning
this looks good but white can take him
okay eight yeah this is this is just
super super difficult
I mean stock fish at a very I mean not
very deep analysis death gives black 0.8
which you don't quite know what it means
tough okay he went c5 I had to play very
quickly Queen deform see 6b 6b 3 so here
Queen d6 was losing okay and Quincy 5
was a bit better for me
so this is losing due to this okay yeah
yeah it is what it is so if I do this
okay a queen even yeah you can also do
this the problem is this trick this is
the problem I was very lucky then I mean
okay here he started to have low time as
well some kind of understandable and
here maybe Quincy five was better I
don't know Quincy five takes it's not
better though yeah this is a funky move
it was funny the ideas to do this and
all of a sudden black wins nice the move
that keeps the balance he has aged three
okay nobody is going to play that for me
okay in the game we got this ending
which is equal at first but then some
some weird things happened really
chief chief is just one of those moves
that you accrue who maybe it's not the
end of the world I should play King D
six here iam this is just bad chest
it shouldn't work you know I should go
before and my night has no good squares
and white is winning then and here king
of - it's still better for white people
and he can still draw with King if I am
hmm is that so King if go yeah that's
that's wrong that's wrong I can you know
let's say here in three a six and then
just staying problem nope sorry and it's
a draw yeah
so only only after this it was it was
completely lost
now I'm winning the pawn for fun for
nothing basically yeah tough a tough
game for sure okay guys thanks for
watching